thanks for having me here I'm gonna talk
about sub linear algorithms and the
title is a sort of a take-off on a movie
that I think came out in the 90s about
called fast cheap and out of control but
about it had Brad Brooks and an elephant
trainer and a topiary garden area and
basically four people that were a bit
crazy and they and I liked the title and
it seemed sort of apt for today's talk
okay so what I'm interested in is
algorithms that are good for really big
data it's so big the data that it
doesn't actually fit into your computer
and in fact part one I'm gonna talk
about the case where you just don't have
time to even view all the data okay so
what can you hope to do in such a
setting let me just to make this
concrete let's start with an example
that um in this country a lot of people
have heard of but in countries such as
Israel they've never heard of this
phenomenon so this is the small world
phenomenon and they say okay let's take
the social network this is a graph each
node is a person and if I know you like
if I know Mike then we have an edge
between us and I know dick I have
another edge between up now the question
is are all pairs of people connected by
a path of distance at most six okay so
this was the famous Milgram experiment
they claimed to show that this is true
when I give this talk in Israel they're
like what do you mean six cuz it's two
for 1.3 or something like that and they
don't know what I'm even talking about
they've never heard of it because it
doesn't even register there okay so but
here it holds and you know there was a
play about this and a lot of press okay
so the question is is it really true I
mean people say this Milgram experiment
didn't really prove anything so is it
really true that everybody's connected
by a path of distance at most six the
question is how would you test this are
you gonna go around asking everybody in
this room who do you know like start
listing everybody you've ever met and
then
go do this to every single person in the
whole country and then check if they
really are if there's really a path of
most six between every pair I mean this
is sort of a crazy amount of data by the
time you do this somebody might die and
that might change the situation if you
asked this question over the whole world
you might never know because there might
be like some little island that has
somebody there that was born on the
island because it's parents like washed
up there and and then they never met
anybody and isn't connected at all to
the universe okay so these things happen
I mean they do find kind of tribes of
people that were sort of disconnected
from the rest of the world in various
like kind of remote locations and and so
this sometimes happen you can maybe
assume that it can't be too many people
otherwise they'd be generating so much
energy that we would have seen noticed
something about them but so you can
maybe assume something about the number
of such crazy situations you can maybe
assume something about the speed at
which things change but in general how
would we even test such a thing all
right
so in general what's the problem with
vast data it's impossible to access it's
um even if it's potentially all of the
acts of the data that you could
potentially access you just don't have
time to access all of it and finally
once you access it the data can change
so we have this gold standard Eddie
talked about polynomial time algorithms
that was our goal even better linear
time algorithms that's another goal
that's a harder goal okay
but even this might be inadequate okay
so what can you hope to do in this case
okay so this is this is the gold star
that you get when you take undergraduate
algorithms and you find the linear time
algorithm that gives you an A+ in the
class the question is is that good
enough for us okay so what can you hope
to do well we're going to have to modify
our goals we're not going to be able to
answer and for all or exactly type
questions for example we are not going
to be able to say exactly how many
people on this earth are left-handed and
in fact why would we even care because
of the birth-death situation the data is
changing we don't really care exactly
what we'll have to do
is approximate we won't actually be able
to answer whether all individuals in
this world are connected by six degrees
of separation
the compromise we'll have to make is to
ask approximately how many individuals
on earth they're left-handed and you
know this is this is why this is the
only data you'd ever see anyway when if
you read the newspaper and they give you
a data on how many people are
left-handed
they never tell you you know an exact
number they give you an approximate
number right so similarly what will hope
to be able to say is is there a large
group say 99% of the country is
connected by at most six degrees of
separation okay so that's the type of
compromise we're gonna have to make and
I want to talk about two types of
compromises or approximations one is
property testing which I'll define in a
moment and I'll start with that and the
other is the traditional notions of
approximation where you're trying to
approximate a number or you're trying to
come up with a solution that is you know
good is you know it's at least 99
percent as good as the optimal solution
okay or it's within a factor of two of
the optimal solution something like that
so that's traditional approximation but
let me start with the weirder one first
and these are tests of data you want to
know does it have a certain type of
property okay so in this graph of you
know I know Lenore Lenora knows men well
and then well nose dick in that graph of
who knows who what is the what is this
are we do we have the six degrees of
separation property or not
okay so there's it's like a bit we want
to know yes or no okay so we want to
distinguish inputs that have the
specific property from those not those
that don't have the property but those
that are far from having the property so
why I like to think of these is in the
ballpark tests so I know you like
baseball let's see you're either in the
ballpark
or you're out of the ballpark but kind
of if you're on the on the border here
like hanging off the lights
then a a you know why I say hanging off
the lights because there was that guy in
the earthquake in 1989 but swung from
the light
but he's the East data life okay but
these are they in the ballpark or not in
the ballpark if they're just swinging
during an earthquake kind of sometimes
in sometimes out we don't care okay
that's not in this case we can say yes
it has the properties in the ballpark
you can also say no it doesn't have the
property because it's not quite in the
ballpark I don't really care okay but if
you're in the ballpark I want you to say
yes if you're far from being in the
ballpark I want you to say nope
on the border I don't care okay
why do we and that's the approximation
that I say I don't care if I'm on the
edge here I can I tell you you don't I
don't care what you say you can say
whatever you want okay and the fact that
I give you that leeway on the border to
say whatever you want means I can offer
an answer such questions much faster
anyway it might be the natural question
to ask when there's some kind of noise
or when the data is changing and
definitely he gives you a fast sanity
check for ruling out very bad inputs
okay so that's another point also it's
related to um for those of people that
are interested in machine learning in
this audience it's um essentially
related to the model selection problem
in machine learning okay so that's
another reason why you might be
interested in this type of question so
what's the requirement of our property
tester if the input has the property
we're supposed to pass if the input is
far from having the property and I will
define what I mean by far in a minute
then we need to fail okay now we have
randomized algorithms they're going to
be sampling sometimes they're just gonna
be wrong okay just because they made
stupid choices like the the make choices
randomly and where to look and sometimes
you're just unlucky you know and it
looks like the thing has the property
cuz you never looked at the place where
it doesn't have the property and you
were just unlucky with how you tossed
your coins so you might make a mistake
and think the input has the property
when it doesn't you might also think
it's far from having the property when
it actually does have the property for
some reason okay so we're gonna just say
you have to give the right answer with
high probability you know if it has the
property right if it has the property
then with very high probability you
should say Pass is it's far from having
the property with high probability
should say fail in the in-between cases
I don't care
you can sometimes they pass sometimes
they fail you can always say pass I
don't care what you do okay so I need to
specify two things here what is epsilon
fire what does it mean far from having
the property so this really depends on
your setting like it depends on your
situation and what you care about I'm
gonna give some examples today so today
when I talk about far I mean that the
input has to be changed and say epsilon
fraction of the locations in order to
make it have the property so it's
something we'll call of a Hamming
distance it's the number it's the
fraction of locations I've got to change
the input and to make it have the
property okay and I'll give an example
in a minute okay so here's the example
okay so here's an example I want to test
if a list is sorted use it alphabetize
did you know is my L is my phone book
alphabetized here's a list of names y1
through an and I want to know is this
list sorted well to determine that
precisely the old way I'd have to go
through the whole list and look at every
way I and check the Y I plus one is
bigger than Y I can do that in linear
time you know I can just go read every
one yeah that's bigger than that that's
bigger than that and go on and that's
fine okay but if I want to do something
in sublinear time
okay um I can't distinguish the case
where all of them are sorted from the
case that even one isn't sorted because
there might be just one thing that's
wrong like that's out of place and if I
don't see it in my random sample then I
won't know about it okay
so what we're trying to say is our goal
is to quickly test if the list is close
to sorted okay so what I want to talk
about what do I mean by quickly and what
do I mean by close to so quickly I mean
the query complexity is measured in
terms of the list size and so this I've
got n numbers and I'm gonna talk about
how many numbers I need to look at in
this list in order to decide if it's
close to sorted and our goal is to get
something sub linear in N and we're
actually gonna go for something that
looks like a logarithmic in n okay so
it'll be fairly easy to see some square
root n type
but we're gonna go for logarithmic
second um what do I mean by close what
do I mean by the list being close to
sorted I mean the list of size n is
epsilon close to being sorted if I can
delete and most epsilon fraction of the
elements to make it sorted so so here's
some example so epsilon is given to me
as an input somebody tells me I want to
test if this thing is sorted or most or
at least like one over ten far from
sorted okay
so here's a list that's sorted here's a
list that's close to sorted if I kind of
deleted these three elements this thing
would be sorted right and there that's
mean I deleted them now that's a sorted
list and this thing is kind of far from
sorted because of these 345 3923 I can
only keep it most one and then it's
followed by the ones I have to figure
out I either keep the one or I keep one
of those so let's get rid of all three
of those and you know what you go
through this thing and you every time
you have a decreasing sequence you can
only keep it most one of those sequence
and maybe not even so in the end this is
the closest us this is the closest
sorted sequence that I managed to find
from this example okay I had to delete
half the list to get here to a sorted
list okay so this it this is a sequence
that's far from sorted this is a
sequence that's close to sorted and this
is of course sorted all right so what we
want from the algorithm is it should
pass sorted list fail lists that are
epsilon far and I'm going to use the
contrapositive here you know if P
implies Q that's equivalent to saying
not Q implies not P that's how we always
do our proofs here okay so I'm gonna
prove not Q implies not P in other words
I'm going to say if it's I want to say
okay what we said before was if the list
is sorted you should pass and if the
list is epsilon far from sorted you
should fail instead what we're going to
prove is if you're likely to pass in
other words not fail okay if you're
likely to pass then it must be that
you're close to sorted okay so not
just making clear because um it's always
confuses everybody when I teach this so
I want a sorted employees pass and I
want epsilon far implies fail and of
course this is with high probability so
I want not this meaning I'm likely to
pass implies not this that I'm epsilon
close yeah excellent far oh okay so
epsilon far means I need to delete at
least epsilon fraction of the elements
to get it to be sorted okay okay epsilon
fraction but I know how the list is of
length ends so I need to delete at least
epsilon times and many elements okay any
other questions you can think of it is
um I'm gonna give you a running time in
terms of epsilon it's gonna be one over
epsilon time in this login so you can
think of it however you want and then
you can decide if this algorithm is
useful for you based on what you decided
epsilon is so but you could say that
epsilon if it's you know if you really
need to know if the list is one over a
million close to sorted and your list is
only size 100,000 then you might as well
just look at everything so I guess that
sort of the trade-off okay I want to
mention we're gonna ask for a certain
probability of success that's a constant
at least a constant bigger than 1/2 its
standard and we're going to use the
standard tools in our field of just you
know if I get it right with probably at
least 3/4 I and you want it right with
probability Delta like you want
probability of error at most Delta you
want to always do you know maybe you
want one minus one in the number of
atoms in the universe I can repeat this
test log 1 over Delta x and get you
error probability at most Delta okay so
it's totally standard so I'm always
gonna look for I'm gonna ignore Delta
for almost everything in this talk
except for maybe one line at a certain
place place where I mentioned Erica
prices result if I get there okay so
away but for the most part I'm just
going for constant probabilities because
of that okay so now remember if the list
is not sorted but not far I don't really
care you know it's okay for me to say
that it's sorted because it's not
epsilon far it's also okay for me to say
that it's not sorted because it's not
actually sorted so that's true but it's
not sorry it's not sorted so you know
it's sort of you know in some sense
either way science progressed like I
either know that I'm close to being
sorted or I know I know that I found a
place
to not sort it so either way I got some
kind of information out of that but I
don't have to decide which type of
information I get for these guys in the
middle the fact that I didn't decide on
them gives me this flexibility that
allows me to get much much faster
algorithms okay and it turns out this
we're gonna be able to test in one over
epsilon times log in time time so this
is there should be a parentheses around
the one over epsilon times login time
and you can't do any better alright so
here's a proposed algorithm this is like
a first attempt one thing I might do is
just pick a random index look at X sub I
look at X sub I plus 1 I'm sorry Y sub I
and y sub I plus want to make sure
they're at the right order so just look
at neighbors okay so let's see what
happens here in just a minute okay I
pick a random neighbor here well you
know it's always the case and the sorted
inputs it why I plus one is bigger than
Y I hear it's um you know except for
these three places the test would pass
you know if I asked here here here here
or here or even here the test would pass
there's only a couple of places where
the test doesn't pass here here and here
so three out of all those other places
where the test doesn't actually pass
okay the test will pass some of the time
but the pets will pass most of the time
there's a few places where the test
might not pass when it's far there's a
lot of places where this test won't pass
it won't pass here here here or here
yeah it will pass here it won't pass
here I mean there's a ton of places
every place where Y I is bigger than Y I
plus 1 this thing is gonna fail so it's
gonna do the right thing on this it's
gonna do the right thing on this and
here we said we don't care everything's
right alright so that seems like a good
idea except then there's this bad input
type okay and this bad input type takes
them
it just says okay I'm gonna take the
following input I'm gonna write 1 2 3 4
5 up to n over 4 then 1 2 3 4 5 up to n
or before I do this for tight ok if you
want to look at a picture of this input
it's something like this alright if I
pick a random I
most of the time I land in the middle of
one of these sequences and everything
looks good
but there's only four places where I go
from n over four to one where there's
actually a problem so my probability of
finding a problem here is only four out
of n that's very small
but this thing is extremely far from
being sorted to make this thing sorted I
have to delete at least three-quarters
of the elements okay because you see I
can take 1 2 3 4 up to n over 4 once but
I can't have more than that all right so
that's not good ok so maybe this is a
bad test right because here's a bad
input that passes with high probability
but it's extremely far from being sorted
so that's a bad test what would be
another proposed algorithm what would
you think of I didn't actually place him
but I knew that somebody would suggest
this so I so I um he'll pick random inj
and test that Y is less than or equal to
YJ okay so of course if I mean so pick
random I and J let's say I is less than
J so I've picked two random elements
maybe here and here oh they're in the
right order and I picked maybe two more
random elements that's great so this
sort of thing will obviously pass the
closed ones usually will pass as long as
I don't hit one of these green ones and
maybe it'll even pass if I hit one of
these green ones who knows this guy
though maybe it'll pass maybe it won't I
don't know what happens so let's look
okay so here's a bad input type which is
n over four groups of four decreasing
elements okay so I'm going to look at
four three two one four three two one
then the next group is bigger than any
of these guys but it's also in
decreasing order okay then the next
group is bigger than anything preceding
it but it's also in decreasing order the
next four okay
what is the biggest monotone subsequence
of this thing what is it like how many
nodes do I how many of these numbers do
I have to delete to get a monotone a
sequence I can only keep one of each
group of four so I still have to get rid
of three quarters of them points even in
this example okay but now to pick I and
J and see that Y I is in the wrong order
from Y J I would have to pick two nodes
from the same group okay so we have n
over four groups and I've got to hit the
same group twice that is a birthday
paradox calculation and that we know is
square root n I need support to take
square root and different samples to
find this birthday paradox problem okay
so that's why I'm gonna need for this
test I need root end samples so that's
good it's sublinear but it's not good
enough for us because we were gonna go
for log n right okay well so we said
looking at neighbors isn't good looking
at two random elements that's good but
not great okay so let me just point out
something in the first case we were
looking at things very close together in
the other case when you pick two random
neighbors those guys are usually like
very far apart right that's the problem
usually when you pick two random numbers
is they're usually very far apart what
if you try to look at every possible
distance to to the I you know things
that are about one apart two apart for
apart eight apart sixteen apart you know
all the different distances so there's
only log in sort of buckets of distances
you'd have to look at maybe that's the
right thing to do and that's essentially
what we're gonna do but we're gonna use
our good old friend binary search to do
this okay so let's um let me just assume
that the list is this
because this is something dick carpeted
me that you can assume in the 1980s so
it's an old trick from that you taught
me in the context of parallel computing
but why can I assume the list is
distinct because I want to claim this is
not really an easier problem the fact
that I could have had repetitions of
numbers doesn't really make things
easier because I could have virtually
appended the index I to each X sub I so
instead of looking at a list x1 through
xn I could think of it virtually but in
my head as X 1 comma 1 X 2 comma 2
because I know when I look at it what
the indexes that got me there so I could
just think of it that way and this sort
of breaks ties without without changing
the order so if I had like one that
would go to one one this one would go to
one two this two would go to two three
because it's got and this six goes to
six four and the other six goes to six
five okay so it doesn't change the so if
you think of these now is slightly
bigger numbers I don't have any
duplicates because everybody has a
distinct second digit but also look that
one should still the higher-order digit
I should still be an order according to
the highest order digit so this won't
break the ties yeah yeah but anyway I
was paying a logs okay good point okay
that's actually a very good point I am
paying a log space penalty so I'm kind
of assuming right now that this is
without loss of generality
if these n numbers were log n bit
numbers okay and actually the lower
bound today that's a really good
question because the lower bounds I said
that you need log n time they really
don't hold if you were like trying to
check if a bunch of bits were sorted
like zeros and ones or zeros ones and
two if you had like a constant size set
of numbers sorry
numbers like in the range that's zero to
some constant then you can do much you
can do even better than what I'm
suggesting here so that is a very on
point question but I am assuming here
that it's without loss of generality
only when this
all right so let's assume everybody's
distinct and here's the test we're gonna
do the following thing one over epsilon
many times we're gonna pick a random eye
we're gonna look at the value of y sub I
it's just a number you know look at the
Eiffel occasion it's a number you see a
number like a thousand and one okay
now forget where you found it you know
you know it's the number 1001 that's
what you keep in your head now do binary
search on this list it's supposed to be
sorted for a thousand and one you better
end up where you started
like assuming that this list really was
distinct you're supposed to end up where
you started right yes if it was sorted
okay so so if somehow you didn't end up
at the right place or if you had an
inconsistency in the binary search like
you went left and the numbers got bigger
or you went right and the numbers got
smaller that's not good
then you fail this list you say this
list is not in sorted order
but and if you don't end up at location
I you fail this list because there must
have been some problem here and if you
did this thing one over epsilon many
times you pet and you never failed it
then you can pass okay so this running
time is one over epsilon log n let's see
what it would have done in our example
back here okay here I pick a random
location okay so pick a random location
I end up at 23 I do binary search I'm
gonna end up at this location if I do
binary search for 23 cuz that's nice
thing about binary search on a sorted
list here that might happen if I like
pick the number 5 let's say I blend
first I look at 14 I say 5 is less than
14 so I will go left in fact that might
be the next thing I look at so I see 5
where I'm supposed to see 5 great ok it
might not work for me when I go 4 to it
so the list so I'll have a problem in my
binary search when I look for 2 because
I'll start here at 14 I'll say go left
I'll look at 5 I'll go left and then I
might look at 4 and I'll go left and
I'll see one and there's nothing else
there so I'll never find the 2 so it
would fail
okay but a lot of the numbers that I
look for here if I pick at random a lot
of these numbers they'd actually find
them some I might not okay what happens
here well here I'm gonna get really
messed up for example let's see who
should we look for let's say I look for
20 so I first look at five okay
I know twenties bigger so I should go
here I look at two I already see a
problem okay cuz two is smaller than
five I wasn't supposed to get smaller
when I went to the right so they had a
problem in the binary search okay yeah
and I think that's the right way to do
it so so anything that looked at two
would all these guys would see a problem
because they look at two next and they
would um say I wasn't supposed to get
smaller when I went right Yeah right but
that's what the point of it but when it
when the thing is close to sorted but
not sorted I'm allowed to answer fail if
I want so it's kind of this is the
beauty of this definition that it's not
actually sorted so I'm allowed to fail
it but I don't have to if I don't find
the problem so that's kind of the leeway
there but I want to prove to you
actually that this algorithm actually
works not just on my examples but in
general okay so let's just say index I
is good so this is just a one slide
proof if you don't like it I move on to
the next slide in a minute okay I want
to see the index I is good if when I did
the binary search for y sub I it was
actually successful so y sub I is the
item that was located in location I and
now I look think of that as the number I
do binary search and if I end up in
location Y sub I look if I end up in
location I ice and I never had a problem
I never went left and got bigger I never
went right and got smaller as long as
that happens the binary search for y sub
I is successful it took me logarithmic
time to do that but that's how I can
tell okay
so what is the test restated we're gonna
pick
one over epsilon size sample of these
locations I and pass if they're all good
okay that's what our test is that we'd
had on the previous life says to do okay
and that takes one over epsilon log and
time because for each to check if you're
good it takes a logarithmic time all
right so now what's the correct is if
the list is sorted then all the eyes are
good okay this is for this part that's
where we use the distinctness the other
one I mean if you weren't distinct and
you might not actually end up at your
location you might end up at some other
location like maybe the one right before
you or maybe if there was a run of ten
things the same weight then you might
have ended up at any one of them so I
don't know about that but if you're
distinct the test always passes if the
list is remember we're doing now if the
list is likely to pass not this implies
not this I want to show if it's likely
to pass then it's epsilon close that's
equivalent to saying that if it's
epsilon far then we're gonna fail
okay so if it's likely to pass then
what's the first thing just because we
sampled if it's likely to pass the test
then we know that because we took a
sample of size one over epsilon there
can't be more than epsilon fraction of
bad eyes okay so we can assume that at
least one minus epsilon and fraction of
the eyes are good that's just sampling I
haven't done anything yet
okay now the main observation is if I
look at all these good elements they
have to be in the right order so 1 minus
epsilon fraction of the elements are
good now what I want to show you is any
set of good elements must be in the
right order
okay and why is that because let's take
a pair I less than J okay so let's say I
is good and J is good and I did some
kind of binary search which we can think
of sort of a tree I start in the middle
and then I
I&J a little closer okay so I start I do
some search I look at first it's the
middle guy and then I and then then the
next thing I do is look in a in the
middle of this I start in the middle I
go here and then maybe I go here and
then here and then and follow some path
to I and follow some path to J when I do
my binary search okay and at some point
it the least common ancestor of I and J
so in the binary search for I I found I
in the binary search for J I found J
there is some path okay let's look at
the least common ancestor of I and J so
this is the place that we're gonna call
K that's the place we looked at where
after we looked at location K I was less
than K so we went left J was bigger than
K so we went right okay that's the least
common ancestor of my search path and
for them to diverge because we assumed I
is less than J it has to be there was
some place where we went left for I and
right for J at that place we know that
the value of location I Y sub I is less
than or equal to Y sub K so we have that
Y sub I is less than or equal to Y sub K
that's because we went left
and we also know that Y sub J is bigger
than or equal to Y sub K that's because
J went right okay so we're just using
basic binary search properties that's
all we're doing and then we have because
this is smaller than K and this is
bigger than K then why I must be less
than or equal to Y sub J so great it
means they're in the right order
so if I take any group of good elements
of which I have 1 minus epsilon fraction
they're all a pair wise in the right
order
and that means I have a large monotone
increasing subsequence of size 1 minus
epsilon times n ok so that's all I have
to do okay questions on this
okay and to make this list monotone all
we've to do is delete the epsilon times
and fraction the epsilon times and bad
elements and then we're done okay so
that's that's the kind of the example so
in general how would you construct a
property tester you have to find some
characterization of the property that
somehow efficiently testable here we use
some kind of binary search idea and it's
robust it in the sense that the objects
they have the property satisfied the
characterization and if you saw in the
monotonicity test that for us was the
easy site with a harder thing usually is
to show that objects that are far from
having the property are actually
unlikely to pass and that was where we
did the work of defining the good
elements and saying okay I you know most
of the elements are good and good things
have this nice property that because we
did this binary search thing we know
they're in the right order okay so
that's where we did the work all right
so that's usually the bigger challenge
let me give another example you let's
say you want to test a program like when
I was a PhD student here I worked with
min well and we sum up I'm testing
whether programs were correct you can't
test the program on every single input
okay so you can think of the you know
you can query the program at any
specific input but you can't look at it
on every single input because it way too
much time so now I want to see if this
program is reasonable well it's supposed
to be commuted it made me it's a program
for Multi matrix multiplication it's not
supposed to be commutative but it is
supposed to be associative so maybe I
could somehow test it it's associative
or maybe I could test that it satisfies
the distributive property okay
so there's some property like that where
I can't go through every single input
and test does it really satisfy the
distributive property but maybe there's
some way I can show that this function
has the right structure or for most
inputs has the right structure and
that's the idea so you'd like to test if
a function is a homomorphism or what we
call a linear function that f of X plus
y is equal to f of X plus F of Y for all
x and y you can test that in constant
time independent of the size of the
domain okay you can I mean meaning that
you can separate programs that are that
are that satisfy this homomorphism
property for
that's why from programs that are not
close to any function that is a
homomorphism on more than one minus
epsilon fraction of the inputs okay so
you so it's actually not just testing
that it satisfies for all XY most of the
time but it's actually testing that
you're close to a specific are still
some homomorphism on 1 minus epsilon
fraction of the inputs another example
is you can test if a sparse social
network graph has six degrees of
separation also in constant time if you
allow this notion of distance okay so
let me just give some example of the
homomorphism property of functions a bad
testing characterization would ask you
for all XY f of x plus f of y equals f
of x plus y you cannot test all x and y
another bad characterization is you
wouldn't want to just pick random x's
and test fit mostly f of x plus f of 1
is equal to f of x plus 1
i think now you have some intuition from
the monotonicity testing example of how
this could go terribly wrong okay and
here's a good characterization for most
XY f of x plus f of y equals f of x plus
y so it's clear the good homomorphisms
they satisfy this for all x y they will
pass but what is a little bit harder to
prove is that the only thing that passes
this test for most XY are actually
functions that agree with some
homomorphism on most inputs and just a
warning um it's not just what you have
to prove to show that these
characterizations are robust it's not
just some like simple statistical
property in fact it's not even true for
most um you know for all versions of
most you need this most to be at least
seven ninths otherwise it completely
breaks down okay so you know usually in
statistics you don't just break down at
seven nine so yeah this is a
homomorphism that's the definition
it satisfies this I mean that's what we
were testing so of it yeah so it's
supposed to be over a group let's forget
about that for now but I mean let's
pretend they but but let me assume we
are talking about discrete domains here
for the most part okay so I'm talking
about things over you can it doesn't
have to be discrete deal names like
finite groups
it could be subsets of infinite groups
you can do that
it's a look it's much more messy but you
can do it using the same kinds of ideas
but it has to be a discrete domain so it
has to be a discrete set of the X's have
to come from a discrete domain okay for
six degrees of separation here's too bad
testing characterizations for every node
all other nodes should be within
distance six so you can't test that
because how would you go check every
other node and see if it's really within
distance six for most nodes all other
nodes are with distance six that's also
really hard to check it anytime you
above all it's bad news but here's a
good characterization for most nodes
there are many other nodes within
distance six and that turns out to be
pretty good okay this definition of
closeness okay I want to mention that
many more properties have been studied
over graphs functions point set strings
and actually there's some amazing
characterizations of prop problems
testable in both graphs and function
testing models so I mentioned a bunch of
properties of functions linearity low
total degree polynomial monotone convex
sub modular again these are over
discrete domain so it's some kind of
discretization of these notions yes
quinta is it means that it's a function
of like an n-dimensional it's a function
in an n-dimensional domain but it only
depends on a small number of the
locations so a dictator function
actually maybe only looks at the ice
location even though there's n minus 1
other locations you can look at in the
input it only looks at the ice location
and based on that
it's a decision a hanta might look at k
locations and based on that make a
decision okay so it's really like what
you would think of from the South
American politics
okay so there's lots of properties and
functions that people look at properties
of graphs for dense graphs it's
completely characterized the so it's
sort of a weird thing for dense graphs
most of the graph properties you've
heard for dense graphs I'm thinking of
you know adjacency matrix we say it's
far if you have to change at least
epsilon N squared of the edges to make
it have the property so it's like a very
dense graph there it's completely
characterize what's testable and almost
all the graph properties you can think
of like colorable by um small cut large
cut not smoke up at large cut and they
all the interesting properties that they
people come up with for dense graphs
different kinds of partition properties
they're all testable in constant time
except the only natural thing I know of
that is not constant time testable or
needs linear time to test so kind of
either it needs linear time or it's
constant time testable the only thing
that's in the middle is graph
isomorphism and that has that's the only
example I know that's natural that is
not either constant time or linear time
that's for dense graph that's the story
for them it's amazing
work it's very deep mathematically I'm
not gonna even try to explain that to
you and it depends on a to show this
this summer Eddie regularity lemma and
all sorts of beautifully extensions of
it okay hyper finite graph is kind of
the don't get scared of that word what
that just means is the graph is actually
a very example minor free graphs are
hyper finite planar graphs are you know
for example my planar graphs they're
really non expanding okay and what it
means is I can remove epsilon fraction
of the edges and break and shatter the
graph into small connected components so
it there exists a way to remove a small
fraction of the edges and completely
shatter this graph into small pieces of
sighs polynomial in one over epsilon not
even a log vector just constant size
components that depend only on Epsilon
okay so those are hyper finite graph
planar graphs are a good example all
minor free graphs fit in that um and a
so it's completely characterize what's
testable in that model and pretty much
everything is testable in that model in
that type of graph and general sparse
graphs which may be expanders or may be
part expanders in one section and very
non expanding in another section there
it's a little bit trickier and there's a
lot of work to do but there are some
results of giving sub-linear time
testers for things like bipartite nurse
connectivity diameter color ability
expansions rapid mixing is the graph
triangle three so there's a bunch of
things lots of nice tools I mentioned
some already regularity lemma also
random walks local search simulated
greedy borrowing from parallel
algorithms which I'll say a bit more of
about in a minute okay so some other
combinatorial properties are four sets
strings metric properties um oh a
standstill here okay
clustering if you want to ask he's the
guy to ask about clustering so you
should you've got the man here okay good
so what else okay so this is there's
still a lot of questions of things that
we don't know how to property test
it's sort of an active area lots of
people working in it and lots of results
kind of hard to even keep track of okay
I want to move to classical
approximation and talk about not how to
test it if your input has a property or
not but to estimate some parameter of it
okay so maybe I want to know the size of
a minimum spanning tree I want to
estimate the size of the min spanning
tree or I want to estimate the size of a
vertex cover or I want to as to make the
size of a max cut or the size of an of a
large matching you know positive linear
program any distance these are all
things that have been considered in this
model and there are sub linear time
algorithms for them I'm going to give a
a very simple example just to see it's
just it's actually the one example I
know of of a sub linear time
deterministic
approximation algorithm the rest are all
randomized and we're gonna get an
approximate answer and of course it's
sub-linear time so here we're gonna give
you a matrix of distances between
endpoints so it's an M by M matrix or
input size is M Squared okay and the pIJ
is the distance from I to J we're gonna
assume that this distance matrix
satisfies triangle inequality and
symmetric okay but notice the input size
is the number of points squared I'm
gonna get you something because I
because it's kind of an arbitrary
symmetric triangle inequality distance
matrix okay now let I J be the indices
that maximize D IJ okay so these are the
farthest two points in this metric space
okay and then if that's the case we call
D IJ the diameter okay so these are the
farthest two points that's the diameter
of our point set okay all right
what we want to do is we want to output
KL so the two points K and else of it
the distance between K and L is at least
half the diameter so this is a to
approximation to multiplicative
approximation okay that's the goal and
we're gonna do this in time order M
where the input size is n which is M
squared so it's gonna be square root the
input size okay so here's the algorithm
just pick an arbitrary point K and then
take the farthest point from tape so L
is the thing that maximizes detail it's
the farthest point from cake how much
time did I need to do that I just need
to go down Kay's row and see who's the
farthest point from K so this just takes
me order the number of points time which
is square root the size of the matrix
okay all right so that's it that's the
whole thing and I claimed that's at
least half the diameter okay why um well
let's say I and J where the real
diameter these were the real farthest
two points okay well okay
okay so the distance between I and J is
shorter by triangle inequality then if I
went from I to K and then from k2 j
right okay so if I be gone like this
that would be a longer way to get from I
to J but this is less than or equal to
that because I chose this to be the
farthest point from K you know I chose
this to be the maximum edge adjacent to
K so I know that this is smaller than
this guy and I also know that this guy
is smaller than this guy all right so I
know that VI k is less than decal and DK
j is less than decal and I'm using here
the algorithm because it picked the
farthest point from K as well as
symmetry because I flipped it flipped
something here this guy dik is used the
fact that di K and D ki are the same
okay so uh okay so it's simple right and
now I'm done so now D IJ is at most D 2
times D kale okay so this thing so D
kale is at least half the edges so
that's it that's the whole thing okay
this really how this deterministic when
they're picking K arbitrarily your point
okay I could pick K to be the first
point and this would still work yeah so
that's a good question yeah okay so this
was found this was this is a really old
example do to indict from late 90s and
it's I think one of the first sub linear
approximation that I know of maybe you
guys know more all right but okay that
was kind of a specific case you know
like I don't even know how to do that
kind of thing on a graph like how do I
find the diameter or graph or how do I
find the diameter of points where I
don't get their inputs as a metric space
but actually there's some like nice
function that tells me you know the
input may be the input is just the
location of the points on the grid then
I then I don't know how to do this thing
in
some linear time okay so how do we
develop techniques for this field that
works for families a problem so the
answer is there are techniques that work
for families of problems but before I
show you that I'm gonna first show you a
slightly different model okay and here
we have not only large inputs but also
large outputs okay so I don't have time
to look at all the input but the output
of this function was supposed to be big
what do I mean by big like maybe I want
actually to compute the maximal
independent set of a very large graph
but do I really have to compute the
whole maximal independent set just to
figure I'd just want to know am I in it
okay maybe what we want to do a whole
scheduling problem we want to schedule
all of us to use the tennis courts I
don't really care when Manuela gets
scheduled for the tennis courts I
wouldn't know when do I get scheduled
for the tennis court so I have to
compute the whole optimization problem
just to figure out when my tennis time
is I don't even play tennis I so I
really don't want to do that okay okay
so here we're in the setting where we
have large inputs large outputs like
okay when you don't need to see all the
outputs do you really need to see all
the input that's the question and there
are lots of cases where you don't need
to okay so for example locally decodable
codes what do they say I have the input
is a big code is a big message sorry the
input is a big encoded message okay and
I don't really want to know the whole
message I just want to know the ice
location of the message can I figure out
the ice location of the message without
decoding the whole big thing and the
answer is yes I can do that much faster
than decoding the whole thing local
decompression if I have like a whole
genome Bank and I've compressed it and
I'm really using the fact that most
people's genomes have a lot of
similarities but now I just want to do
some kind of binary search on one
person's genome to find something and do
I have to decompress the whole gene bank
no I can do local decompression okay so
there are these notions out there local
generation of random objects this is one
that's taking off recently but what I'm
going to talk about now is really thing
such as estimating graph parameters so
people have looked at so I actually want
to say this is a place where computer
science Electrical Engineering /
information theory physics mathematics
have converged on something called local
algorithms and it's really there's some
piece of the output I want to compute
it's interesting to us how do we do it
and all of these communities have been
looking at similar problems and because
of this I will put in a plug there is a
sequence of workshops called Walla
workshop on local algorithms there was
one held last fall at MIT and MSR a New
England and there's gonna be one held
this summer in June at MIT and they were
trying to get all these people to talk
to each other because everybody's
looking at similar problems everybody
has their own bag of tricks and we're
trying the process of trying to
understand everybody's a vocabulary at
first and and how they do things but so
there's this whole area I'm gonna just
give you one candidate unifying model
there's this large input X there's this
large input that's written down let's
assume we have random access to it last
time I gave that the talk in this room I
was told that's not a reasonable
assumption but anyway let's assume it
for now we have random access to these
guys we then there's some output that is
not written down nobody even knows what
it is because nobody's computed it okay
now what I want to do is design this
algorithm we're gonna call it the local
computation algorithm and what this does
is it gets queries like some user says
I'm interested in location I want I'm
interested in location I - and you send
it to this as local computation
algorithm and he says oh okay I'm gonna
figure out I'm gonna make some queries
to input X and figure out here's y sub I
1 that's what that's the value of y sub
i1 here's the value of y sub I - and
every time I ask it about a new location
maybe I'm doing binary search based on
what I see he'll give it to me okay just
to make things more concrete when I talk
I'm gonna say that the queries that the
LCA makes to the inputs every time it
looks
the input we'll call that a probe and
every time I make a query to the user
makes a query to the LCA and asks about
a different location of why we're gonna
call that a query okay so let's think
about maximal independent set this is
not actually an optimization problem
because I may want to know the size of
some maximal independent set or I just
want it in particular what I'm
interested in is am I in the maximal
independent set in this case okay so a
query to the output is is node you in
the maximal independent set great hold
that hold that question okay
don't quote the question sometimes a a
kid let's hold it for a second hold it
just for a second okay there's a very
good question okay here's a maximal
independent set question I algorithm
they I could run I could run something
that I'm gonna just for today called the
lazy greedy algorithm okay so initially
the local computation algorithm assumes
that this maximal independent set is
completely empty and when it gets a
query that asks is node you in the
maximal independent set then it kind of
checks and sees did I put the neighbors
in the maximal independent set yet and
if not it says yes sure I put them in I
know if one of the neighbors are in the
maximal independent set then I can't put
them in actually are we all clear on
what maximal independent set is that
does anybody want me to define maximal
independent set just remember okay I'm
gonna define maximal independent set so
in a graph a maximal independent set is
a subset of the of the of the vertices
so let's call this thing I it's a subset
of the vertices such that no two are
connected by an edge that's an
independent set the largest maximum
independent set is np-complete
thanks to dick in his initial paper so
that's like one of the first np-complete
problems but we don't want the biggest
max the biggest independent set what I
want
is something that I can't kind of
greedily increase okay so if I take this
is okay so this is an example that is
not a maximal independent set because
look that's cool okay it's not maximal
because what how do I make it bigger
take this guy and add him in okay now
it's a maximal independent set I can't
add this guy in because he's neighboring
somebody that's in the set I can't add
this guy in and I can't add that guy in
so this is a maximal independent set
there's nobody I can add in just every
node that is not in the maximal
independent set is adjacent to somebody
that is in the maximal independent set
so I cannot add it in okay
so always gonna punt on be maximum
benefit
yes yes I am gonna punt on it um all
right okay I should say I'm doing
maximal independent set because because
I can for a couple of reasons one is we
have results on it and it's easy enough
that I can hope to try to explain it but
actually it doesn't necessarily give you
a good well if I had degree bounded
graphs then I could say something about
the relationship of the maximal
independent set and the maximum
independent set it might not be good
enough for most people's purposes but if
I have a bound of degree D then the
maximal independent set is no more than
D times D factor of D smaller than the
maximum independent set I mean there's
always so that's one thing but more
importantly is this is a really these
can be translated into matching maximal
matching a problems and maximal matching
can be further translated into
approximate maximum matching and maximum
matching is in P that's something we can
do in polynomial time
so approximate maximum is something is
kind of the compromise we pay for being
in sublinear time but we can do
something like that okay so so this is
really you know in itself maybe not
interesting
to most people but I'm still gonna talk
about it okay so this is so now one way
to do maximal independent set
sequentially forget about a forget about
a sequential greedy algorithm for
maximal independent set is look at the
nodes in some order and if so as I go
down the order I look at the first node
or any of its neighbors put in the
maximal independent set no because this
is the first node so put it in the
maximal independent set I look at the
next node have any of its neighbors been
put in the maximal independent set
depends if it was connected to the first
node then I can't put it in the maximal
independent set but if it wasn't
connected to the first node I can put it
in and I just go down the line always
checking have my neighbors been
previously put into the maximal
independent set or not what this is
saying to do is use the queries of the
user as your arbitrary order of doing
this greedy maximal independent set
order okay so it's a strange thing to do
and I don't like it okay I don't like it
for a couple of reasons but one thing is
if you did this you'd have to you have
to remember all your past decisions okay
so you'd have to keep space that
contains all of your past decisions and
write that down and on another hand it's
extremely good because my probe
complexity I just have to look at what I
did with my D neighbors this I'm
assuming this is a degree bounded graph
I just have to look at my D neighbors my
probe complexity is order D what I do
with it is very simple so it's nice but
I have to remember my past choices and
furthermore some pathetic question what
do you mean by the maximal independent
set there may be many maximal
independent sets and in particular my
the maximal independent choice this way
is going to depend on the query order
which is sort of a weird thing to do
because let's say there's we're
computing in the cloud okay and these
LCAs are like running off in the cloud
and there's multiple copies of them
working together okay and I'm trying to
figure out if somebody's in the maximal
independent set and when well over there
is trying to figure out so if somebody
else is in the maximal
the pennant set and maybe we do this at
the same time and we didn't communicate
with each other we may make inconsistent
decisions okay so there's a consistency
problem that comes from the fact that
there are multiple answers and when we
choose the answer we have to be choosing
in the same way so I don't like using
query order because if I wanted to run
multiple copies of these local
computation algorithms they have to talk
to each other and say okay I got this
query you'd better keep that in mind
when you pick the next maximal
independent set okay so they'd have to
be talking to each other continuously
alright so we'd like to avoid these
problems and this is the big problem
it's consistency okay so let's talk
about this model one more time we've got
this input the LCA gets a random string
and some workspace not too much of
either and then there are multiple
maximal independent sets that I could
have picked it's not necessarily
polynomial it could be much bigger and I
flipped that random string and that
somehow selects one of these maximal
independent sets I might not know I mean
I flipped the random string I I don't
know what YK looks like just because I
flipped the random string but that's
gonna fix a specific maximal independent
set and now I'm gonna assume that
everybody that's operating out there in
the cloud all the little copies of this
local computation algorithm that are
running out there in the cloud have the
same random string so we communicate
initially then we go to work okay and
let me tell you that I actually use this
algorithm because yeah okay let's get to
that in mid-to I'm going to tell you how
I use it with constant size random
string okay I gave an I gave a data
structure and algorithms exam to a class
of 300 people okay we don't want them to
sit next to each other right so we need
a maximal independent set you shouldn't
have two people and if we want it to be
big so we and we had a course staff of
15 we had to agree in a bit so we were
like all the same LCA is computing in
the cloud we couldn't talk to all 15 of
us and have a convener sudent walked in
there's 300 of them and they walk in all
at the same time so we had to have each
person head in to have an algorithm in
their head of how to get
maximal independent set out of this and
we had to be consistent so we actually
fixed the maximal independent set in
advance but so we really cheated but we
didn't really fit flip a random string
we computed it gave a concise second
representation and said everybody follow
this one but you could do this okay now
so so the ideas here there's some random
string it gets flipped once everybody
gets the same random string and you have
to answer everybody has to answer
according to this same answer okay we
want that the time to answer to the time
to answer a query the random string the
workspace we want all these things to be
sub linear if possible okay
so this was the picture explaining how
this is me and the TAS and the other
faculty teaching this course and we were
all initially sharing a random string
but after that we answered all queries
independently okay so how do we design
these good LCA what we want to do is
find a maximal independent set algorithm
with a nice property that any node V has
an output that depends only on a few of
the inputs okay so some kind of local
area somehow if we can find this then we
could just figure out what a would have
done for V so if like the answer here
only depended on a few other inputs then
I can just figure it out myself what
would have happened I can just query the
look the inputs here and compute it by
myself
I don't need to query everything but
where do you get and this is like
miracle algorithms right that's I've
never heard of such a thing okay I
thought I'd never heard of such a thing
but then turns out there's this whole
area of distributed computation called
local distributed algorithms ok and what
that means
what that means is these are distributed
algorithms where we work on a network
and we try to compute some property of
the same network the one that we're
communicating on that's the same Network
where we want to compute an independent
set so the input is the same as the
communication network that's like that
seemed really weird to me I always
thought distributed algorithms have a
communication network and then they take
as input some arbitrary graph and they
compute that no in this bottle in local
distributed algorithms model the
communication network is the input ok so
it's just one breath if the input and
the communication network now what do
they get to do in a round in a round
everybody gets to talk to their
neighbors so I get to look talk to all
my neighbors and I get to send each one
their own message and they can all and I
get to receive a message from each one
of my neighbors ok um and so if I have a
K round distributed algorithm for some
problem then what can it depend on well
let's think in one round what can i what
can might if if I have a one round
algorithm for something what can it
depend on my my answer has to depend
only on my neighbors because that's all
I can hear from in one round ok in two
rounds
ok in two rounds I can get messages from
my neighbors in the first round they can
get messages from their neighbors in the
first round and in the second round they
can pass on to me information that was
computed from their neighbors and
whatever they initially had ok but that
means that if I just went and figured
out what the neighbors inputs were I
figure out my neighbors inputs and my
neighbors neighbors inputs ok so I look
at the tube all around me the radius
tube all around me and I look at every
single one of those inputs I can compute
myself what this distributed algorithm
would have done ok so in general for K
rounds the only information I can get is
from things K away then the you know I
so and the things can't weigh that you
know ok so just following this a
argument I can hear from the K rate
all around me and I can read it myself
in the degree of the graph raised to the
K probe that's how big this ball is okay
so I can read and simulate the whole
distributed computation by myself
without the help of my neighbors just by
going there because I have random access
I can go read their values and figure it
out all by myself in D to the K probes
and you would say okay that's
exponential and Eddie just told us we
don't like exponential running times
write D to the K sounds really bad
except we're assuming again for this
part of the talk I'm assuming that the
degree is constant for now let's give me
that and it turns out that in
distributed algorithms they have been
coming up with algorithms where K does
not depend on the size of the input
graph so these this cake is might depend
on one over epsilon but it does not
depend on the size of the input graph
okay so it's amazing work in distributed
local algorithms and I'll say a bit more
about it on the next slide but for them
local is constantly many rounds so K is
constant and that is polynomial in D but
remember the D were thinking of it's
also being constant so it's like
constant to the constant right or let's
just say maybe constant is too touchy of
a word if you care about epsilon which
most people do so let me just say
independent of N and independent of n
okay so let's leave it at that okay so
so that's the beauty that we can make
use of fantastic progress in local
distributed algorithms and you know so
there's these niceiy algorithms you know
I can try to convince you that there
shouldn't be a fast distributed
algorithm for maximal independent set
but it actually turns out there is a
really good one due to Looby and that
doesn't right away give you the best
local computation algorithm but with
additional ideas that build on this
algorithm and use different algorithms
and do some other rounds of things you
can put together and you can get a whole
series of works and these are people
from both the distributed local
algorithms community as well as the
local computation community and
basically right now you know these
people are all working together so it's
hard to kind of
imagine who's where but um I so so not
only did the ideas from distributed
algorithms help with building local
computation algorithms but actually some
of the ideas from local computation
algorithms in turn just improved some of
the distributed algorithms so these kind
of two communities have started talking
to each other in the last few years okay
I think I don't have much time to talk
about there are other basic ideas that
you can use to to build local
computation algorithms but I think I'm
running out of time so I'm gonna just
skip this part because I want to mention
why I got to this local computation
algorithms one is I wanted to tell you
about it and two is um it is sub linear
time and the other thing is I wanted to
mention that there's a connection
between local computation algorithms and
what we talked about before of parameter
estimation that's really simple okay
it's like really I just want to point
out that local computation algorithms
are a stronger thing than parameter
estimation and there's a really simple
way to see this so I'm just gonna take
an example I'm not using maximal
independent set here because because
nobody estimates the size of a maximal
independent set let me switch to
approximate matching approximate maximum
matching okay if I had a local
computation algorithm they told me for
each edge whether it's in the
approximate maximum matching I mean this
this local computation algorithm has to
fix on a single one that's good but it
tells me for each edge whether it's in
the one that this local computation
algorithm is thinking about after it
tossed its random string then what I
would do to estimate the size of this
matching is I just sample several edges
uniformly and ask the LCA on each one of
those edges whether it's in this
particular matching M and then aid up
with the fraction of edges and end the
LCA said was a nap times the total
number of edges and that would give me
an approximation to the size of that
particular approximate maximum matching
but if I had a guarantee that the LCA
approximate matching was big then this
would give me a good estimate of my
approximate maximum matching okay all
right so this is just a simple thing you
can do for any problem so you can use
things like you can do
it's cover approximate vertex cover so
so remember that vertex cover is NP
complete but approximating vertex cover
to a within a factor of two is something
we can do quickly and there are sub
linear time algorithms for approximating
vertex cover so a that's another example
of something you could do with this so
it's a general paradigm that when you
build an LCA you can get a sub linear
time approximation okay what I want to
talk about in my remaining very few
minutes is okay is what happens when the
data actually isn't written down so I'm
completely changing now okay
part two it's only 15 minutes but I'm
completely changing topics because now
there's no data written down at all
what's the data now it's just samples of
some distribution and let me take an
example like the lottery okay you know
there was the New Jersey pick three and
pick four you pick three digits 1 0 2 9
0 2 9 0 to 9 that's pick 3 and you pick
four digits you know you do it four
times that's pick four so in the pick
three there is 10th a thousand right the
simple calculations are the hardest but
a thousand possibilities so you have a
domain of size a thousand and pick four
you have a domain of size 10,000 okay
how do you know if this is lotteries
uniform like let's say I even believe
you that every time you pick it's
independent okay let's say I give you
that but I don't know if your
distribution is even uniform how would I
test that it's a very large domain size
and I need 10,000 different draws to
even see to even hope to see each
element once but we know even that isn't
gonna be enough to see each element once
because of coupon collector so how am I
gonna do this because the picks those
lotteries haven't been even running long
enough for me to see enough draws they
take you know if you do it takes decades
for them to get to enough draws that you
can actually say something about them
alright so this is the issue and there's
even a true story here there's a Polish
Lottery multi latech which is a it's
actually a physical machine with 80
balls every day they choose 20 of the
balls
um and that's how the lottery is run but
the initial and machine they used was
biased the probability of balls 52:59
somehow because of physical properties
were too small okay but this is a case
where n is not that big it's 80 and
furthermore you're taking 20 balls each
day so you're taking a quarter of the
balls each day okay so you're getting
pretty good estimates of these balls and
here thanks to Eric price this is the
picture of the statistics that we get
for each of the balls and you can see
here that fifty to sixty had much lower
probability and people were making lots
of money off of this okay because it
didn't take long for them to realize
that there's a problem with the machine
because the domain size was small and
they were getting lots of samples okay
so that's what happened there but what
do you do with New Jersey pick three
picked four I mean the number that you
will get one draw a day and their n
isn't 80 it's ten thousand so you know
when we did this test when we looked at
this I mean it was a long time ago but
when we did this test it had it you
didn't have as many samples as the size
of the domain and so if you just stuck
the numbers of past lottery hits into
chi-square test and in Excel it said no
confidence that's the answer we got okay
so maybe you want to know something else
about it I'll talk about testing whether
a lottery is a uniform but maybe you
want to know whether the distribution
has a specific entropy you want to
estimate the entropy or you want to
count the number of distinct elements
you want to know something about is it a
monotone distribution or is it like does
it go up and down is a kay modal does it
look like a Gaussian or you know some
other property did well what do they do
in statistics they looked at this before
normally they assume something about it
like maybe that it's sort of a slightly
smooth Lipschitz take function or maybe
they assumed that it was a normal
distribution but they just don't know
the parameters of the normal
distribution so there's some type of
assumptions and actually very little of
the work done before ever actually
assumed that the domain size was
extremely large it was discrete and we
know nothing of
like we know no assumptions no Lipschitz
conditions no no no nothing okay so
these are problems that have been
considered in many places but looking at
the knot sample complexity in terms of
the domain size was a question that we
want to answer and the question that
really I want to rephrase the question
is in order to answer those questions do
you need to estimate the probabilities
of each domain item or can you do
something in you guessed it sub linear
time in the size of the domain okay so I
want to take sub linear samples in the
size of the domain all right and the
question is is this even possible all
right so let's just tell you the bottle
I'm just gonna assume the distribution
that's given to me as a black box I push
a button I get a sample and all I'm
gonna worry about paying for is sample
complexity
I will not in this talk worry about
running time although the running times
are reasonable okay so I get this black
box I'm going to assume that the domain
of the distribution is size n so n
elements in the domain it's discrete p
sub i is the probability that this black
box outputs item i and what i'm
interested in is the sample complexity
of whatever problem it is I'm trying to
solve in terms of n okay so let's look
at a first set of properties our two
distributions similar okay so there's a
lot of questions here if I have two
distributions P and Q I want to know are
they the same or are they far well what
do I mean by that maybe Q is known to
the tester and then this is the question
that's known in statistics as goodness
of fit I may ask is P the uniform
distribution
I mean maybe Q is the uniform
distribution I'm asking is P the uniform
distribution or maybe Q is some specific
Gaussian with a specific parameter and I
ask is P equal to that same distribution
okay or it could be that Q is not known
to me it's actually given via sample so
I'm getting samples of two distributions
maybe July sales and august sales and I
want to know are July sales and
obvious sales behaving the same or are
they actually different enough that I
need a new advertising campaign okay
so let's focus on the first problem is P
uniform the sample complexity of
distinguishing the case where P is
uniform from the case where P is epsilon
far in l1 distance um that's just a let
me just write that do I have a you can
write it here
okay so the that's the l1 distant it's
um just the sum over all I and one
through end of the absolute value of P I
minus Q I so I'm taking all the
differences for each element and I'm
summing up their absolute values okay
and maybe you heard about total
variation distance so the total
variation distance and the l1 distance
are intimately connected to each other
one of them is a factor of two of the
other I mean I one of them is twice as
much as the other and I never remember I
think it's the l1 distance it's twice as
big as the total variation distance all
right okay so um all right so I want it
I want to show that this can be done
much faster than it takes me to actually
learn the distribution to learn the
distribution I need at least linear in
and many samples but actually we can
tell if P is U we can distinguish that
case from the cat case where P is far
from uniform in route on samples okay
and an idea base this is an idea of
going to run is actually let's forget
about the l1 distance for a minute let's
look at the l2 distance squared which is
some P I minus Q I quantity squared so
I'm summing this over every I and let's
just look at this for the case where Q
is uniform because this is what we care
about right now so Q sub I is always 1
over N and then this is just I'm gonna
so just humor me I'm doing like seventh
grade algebra right now okay what's P I
minus one over N squared its P I squared
minus 2 PI over n plus one over N
squared right okay so now let's just
distribute these out into there son
notice now that sum P I is equal to one
and sum of 1 over N squared I'm summing
it n times that gives me exactly 1 over
N okay so that means I it's very simple
to see that this is what I get all right
so I have this l2 squared distance from
uniform and now I've written it as the
collision probability of P that's
exactly the probability that I take two
samples from P and I get the same thing
both times okay so I either get both
either both samples are domain element 1
or both samples are domain element 2 or
both
samples our domain at element 3 and so
on okay so it's I get the same thing
twice
that's the collision probability it's
exactly some P I squared so this is a
known this is a known thing that people
like to work with - um so this was minus
2 over n plus 1 over and so it's minus 1
over n I'm gonna assume I know the
domain size so I know this okay so I can
estimate the collision probability to
get an estimate over the l2 norm squared
because I know this alright and
furthermore this quantity is minimized
for the uniform distribution this is
exactly 1 over N for the uniform
distribution for any other distribution
it's bigger ok so that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna estimate the the
collision probability that's gonna give
us an estimate on the l2 norm squared
and then what do I do
well we know some kind of weak
relationships between the l2 norm and
the l1 norm so we'll try to use them ok
so so basically there's some history
here but the end of the story is ok so
so the end of the story is when you do
that you lose something but in the end
you get you get a root n over epsilon
squared bound and it turns out that
originally with this method we didn't
get the best dependence on root n over
epsilon squared so it turns out there's
like three ways three or four different
ways to estimate closeness to uniformity
there you can actually also count number
of distinct elements or you can use a
chi squared like type of estimator but
they all work and they're all pretty
much optimal for most cases except
except this particular bound of looking
at the number of distinct elements for
various stupid reasons so I'm gonna just
ignore that but I want to mention what I
want to mention is actually a I
mentioned before that I'm only gonna
worry about getting constant probability
of error and then we're gonna just use
that obvious thing of repeating log 1
over beta times to get at most beta
error remember we said that you know
we'll just we said that and I said that
for the rest of this talk that's what
I'm gonna do except for one line well
here's the line so diet chemical is
Ghoulia's people's and price showed
recently that you can actually get very
non-trivial
p-values for this problem in other words
you can get the error the dependent the
dependence of the sample complexity on
your error bounds can be additive as as
opposed to multiplicative and that's a
really cool result but I would leave it
to Eric to tell you about it since he's
here so you can ask him in the break ok
I am so I just want to say that um what
about the problem of testing whether P
is any other known distribution so you
write down a distribution for me you
write down tell me P 1 through P n I
mean tell me q1 through QN write it down
for me don't charge me for looking at
what you wrote down but um now just
charge me for samples I need to take
from P to see if it's equal to that
thing you wrote down I'm gonna still
need square root n over epsilon squared
so obviously I need I need at least that
much because if you wrote down the
uniform distribution I would need at
least that much but I also need it most
that much so this is no harder testing
what we call testing identity is no
harder than testing uniformity
so in some sense actually it's been
shown that uniformity testing is
complete for this type of Univ identity
testing problem ok what I wanted to
mention is when P and Q are both given
by samples and I'm get charged for both
sets of samples then things are actually
harder so we thought it should be also
rooted because everything else was
ruinin but it turned out that it's n to
the 2/3 okay so that was a shock to us
um why is it so different well I think
if there's anything you remember from
this section of the talk is anything we
do with testing distributions really it
can talk about sublinear time and you're
talking about symmetric properties such
as uniformity or its estimating entropy
in the end it all comes down to testing
collisions you look at the collision
statistics how many elements occurred
one time how many elements didn't occur
at all how many elements occurred three
times how many elements occurred three
times from PE and four times from Q
that's the only thing that your
algorithm can depend on and you can make
this formal I'm not going to do it right
now but you can actually formally prove
such a statement that it's only the
collision statistics that matter okay so
that's the first thing in the particular
case of two unknown distributions
you can do is come up with distributions
that are either I mean you can sort of
divide the domain in a random way into
heavy elements and light elements and
make P and Q agree on the heavy elements
okay so the heavy elements will have
identical collision statistics and the
light elements are either the same for P
and Q so in that case P equals Q or
they're very different from P and Q and
that case P and Q are very far but
what's going on in the light so there's
enough light elements that that P is
either identical to Q or far from Q but
on the other hand the collision
statistics of the heavy elements kind of
swamps what's happening on the light
elements and you can't tell what's
happening from the light elements
because it's just completely swamped out
by the variance of the heavy elements
and that's how these lower bounds go and
that's why it's difficult but you can do
it in n to the 2/3 time by looking at
these collision statistics so I'm just
gonna drop this I do want to say that
what I've been talking to about until
now is how to tell where P equals Q or P
is Epsilon far from Q and depending on
your model of Q it's either n to the 1/2
sample complexity or n to the 2/3 sample
complexity both very sub linear but if
what you want to distinguish is whether
they're close or far like I have June
and July fails I know they're not
identical I just want to know are they
close or are they far enough that I
should have a new advertising campaign
okay so I know they're not identical I
don't want to just fail them because
they're they're not identical I want to
distinguish close from far that becomes
harder okay so that requires still
sublinear though I just want to point
that out
you still sublet your samples but it's n
over log n okay and there's some really
beautiful results by Paul valiant and
Greg and Paul valiant and the best
parameters in terms of epsilon have been
attacked by the information theory
people and they just they got them and
also beautiful techniques have been
added by these people like you and yang
have
and some really gorgeous techniques to
the area and very nice proofs so this
has been a great success
I mean 1 to 1000 million ok
in the proofs or the actual effect so in
the proofs I don't know the actual
effect I also don't know here's what I'm
guessing I'm guessing that in the proofs
it's probably terrible just to guess
it's just because that always happens ok
but what happens in reality I don't know
and that's the problem how do you how
would you even test this are you gonna
like run it on every single distribution
I don't know um a it's a good question i
it to be the good open question okay
whether it's a really good point it I
will say though that I remember the
information theory community getting
really excited about estimating entropy
which is something else that's gonna be
n over log n in order n times they
didn't even have the log in and that
even that was really exciting
so not needing n log n was already
pretty cool so okay so I'm gonna skip
this because I'm totally out of time so
I just want to say you can also estimate
independence entropy support size
similar things happen you can estimate
entropy and sublinear time maybe just
I'll give one example you can get a to
approximation to multiplicative
approximation of entropy and n to the
one fourth time in general gamma
multiplicative approximation in n to the
1 over gamma squared time samples but
additive approximations of entropy or
support size need n over log in samples
but Kelso can be done in n over log in
samples so this is a really exciting
result as well so lots of other
properties have been considered and more
and more and more and more and more and
they let's I guess it was pretty
optimistic this morning I
okay
okay so I just I'm gonna finish so our
dependence on n usually sublinear
but it's usually some end to the alpha
for some alpha between 0 & 1 so it's
like n to the 2/3 and to the 1/2 you
know if you're trying to test your
pseudo-random number generator that's
not good enough
like those cryptographers they're always
you know you know they're always looking
for things that are polynomial in the
size of the representation of an element
of the set you know we're not we showed
you can't do that you can't test if a
pseudo-random number generator is giving
you uniform distribution all right so is
this good or bad I mean the
cryptographers would say terrible and
the rest of us are like well that's the
best you can do you know live with it
and so it's not trivial but it's still
daunting ok so the question is can you
do better and okay so how would you get
past the lower bounds you know and
there's been a lot of work in this so
you can look at restrictive I mean
people have looked at restricted classes
of distributions trying to assume
something less than saying okay I don't
want to assume that the distribution was
a Gaussian or normal you know I don't
want to assume that much but maybe I can
assume that it's at most that it's K
modal you know maybe it's bimodal but
maybe it looks kind of like this not
nice and bell-shaped okay so let's
assume less from our or let's just do
the best we can for each distribution
some distributions are really hard to
test but some distributions are pretty
easy so can we at least get a sample
complexity that depends it's competitive
with the best thing you can do for that
distribution and people have looked at
that as well another thing you could do
is look at other distance measures such
as earthmover distance or l 2-norm or
you know there's a bunch of them so
everybody will always ask me about
Colbeck Leibler divergence and that's
always a pain because it goes to
infinite so easily that you can't you
know technically you can't but there are
versions of it that are sort of Quebec
Libre prime that you can do much faster
okay also you could assume more powerful
query models you can assume that you get
samples not just uniformly from P but
that I can say I want a uniformly random
sample from a specific range you know I
want like a uniform sample of something
that somebody bought in July or somebody
that some
that somebody bought in the second week
of July okay so I can make sorts sort of
and that's not always unreasonable
because such more powerful query models
are sometimes given to us by the systems
people so for example I've been working
with a detail detail parameswaran who's
at university of illinois and he wrote a
system called needle tail which allows
you essentially to make a type of
conditional sample query and in fact in
that setting you can do things much
faster okay so you can specify a range I
want a random sample in this range and
then they'll give it to you okay another
example that I think you maybe most of
you have heard of is there was a time
when Google published to all of the end
they took a bunch of text a lot of text
they did a lot of work and they figured
out all the Engram statistics from those
texts right so that what's engrams
so what's a bigram statistic it's the
probability that for any two words
what's the probability this word is
followed by this word okay so they
published it for up to 5 grams I think
so essentially you can use that to get a
type of conditional district a
conditional random sample so there so
the it does give you a more power they
did a lot of work but I can build on it
now that they've done their work and use
it to get a more powerful query right
and so once I get these more powerful
queries many of these tasks that I
talked about earlier can be done much
much much much faster sometimes with no
dependents on ends sometimes with a
logarithmic dependence on it but much
faster so it just depends on if whether
this is a reasonable thing to assume ok
so basically in conclusion I want to say
that distribution testing problems are
everywhere for many problems we need a
lot fewer samples than you might think
there's a lot of cool ideas and
techniques out there I didn't get a
chance to talk about even a small
fraction of them but I just want to say
that I think it's a there's a lot of
recent work in this area so it's it's
been around for 18 years but that lately
it's really taking off and a lot of
people are working at it and it's an
another area kind of at the intersection
of statistics
theoretical computer science and
electrical engineering information
theory people and everybody's coming
together and mathematicians everybody's
coming together and sharing it so I even
cited many of those results that I cited
our people that are not from the
theoretical computer science community
but they're kind of there has now been a
lot of interaction so it's a great thing
and I would be exciting to come join us
[Applause]
for questions yes my website I'm like
what say I've taught sub linear
algorithms several times and each time
it's a bit different so there's
different versions of the course and I
have my lecture notes if they're
handwritten usually and they I try to
have reasonable and reasonable enough
handwriting that I can read it when I'm
up there but I but there but there are
of course it's actually there was a
course taught here on property testing
and others under chiesa teach it oh yeah
so I think it was taught here as well
and the some people okay some people
have been writing textbooks so one of my
former students are now Bhattacharya is
writing a textbook with and also Donna
Braun has written some text some
monographs on it so they're starting to
be more and more information out there
actually in distributing testing a
randomized algorithm doesn't help you
because you could use the distribution
to get your random bits so you could you
a final anointment trick you could take
two samples and if the first ones bigger
than the second you could call that bit
zero and if the second ones bigger than
the first you could call that that I
flipped the one and you could use the
samples from the distribution to
generate your random coin tosses and
then essentially your algorithm would
just be deterministic help that's a good
question actually that's a yeah I don't
know
tell me over the
pretty grateful as usual just the
questions two quick questions down below
about the matching that you mentioned in
your politics in computer vision we
usually need the weighted matching is it
trivial to generalize the weighted
matching I mean when you have weight for
each edge or maximize or minimize the
sample isn't an issue you don't know I
don't know um I remember asking this
question of my former PhD student she
Stefanik and he said yeah you can do it
but I don't remember where it's if it's
written where it's written it might just
be in his head and it's just so
obviously didn't bother to write it but
I don't I don't know there's some chance
I would ask she Stefanik if you know
compared to poverty texting so you're
just saying that we allow linear time
for the construction and you want
something at a time for that for the
construction but we do have a third rule
intuitively when I can do something in
Slovenia time you know I must do it in a
time I mean what kind of problems we
have a quick chance to solve is stopping
at I wonder what assumptions yes so in
general I don't have a firm rule but um
for for example for it for a graph
properties of I mean for graph
properties we even have a theorem that
exactly characterizes which graph
properties are testable in constant time
so that's pretty strong we also have it
for hyperfine a graphs example we don't
have any any such yeah and I don't
really have a good feel for that yet cuz
it I only know of a couple of examples
okay thanks for an amazing time
[Applause]